футболки що висміюють Санкції ЄС
продаються на Ура не лише ці
підприємливі росіяни але й вся
Кремлівська Пропаганда підкреслена
демонструє чи Європа їх не налякала і
все ж як стверджують аналітики російське
економіка вже нині потерпає від санкцій
Євросоюз вирішив продовжити штрафну
політику і це схоже значною мірою
заслуга канцлерки ангели Меркель
елементарне питання перемир’я наразі не
вирішене Не кажучи вже про майбутній
статус та співпрацю між луганською та
донецькою областями з українським урядом
кордони цих регіонах досі не захищені
контролю немає буферних зон теж А це все
мінімальні передумови для того щоб
принаймні замислитися про можливість
відкликання санкцій ми від цього ще є на
жаль дуже-дуже віддалені
тривалий час здавалося що німецька
дипломатія веде обережно політику щодо
Росії Берлін все ще сподівається на
діалог з Москвою але з огляду на те що
дипломатія досі не спрацьовувала
офіційні заяви стали різкішими
і це президент не будь-якої країни а
постійного члена Ради Безпеки ООН Росія
анексувавши Крим в односторонньому
порядку змінила існуючі кордони в Європі
порушивши тим самим міжнародне право
цьому небезпечному сигналу Ми мусимо
протистояти бо не можна дозволяти щоб
міжнародне право було знехтувано і щоб
ворон знову відбувся розкол на захід і
Схід
через Таку позицію німецький уряд у
власній країні нерідко наштовхуються на
критику передусім з боку опозиційної
лівої партії та закидає правлячі
коаліції занадто про українську позицію
можливо саме захід має зробити перший
крок назад тоді можна і від Путіна
вимагати щоби він зробив крок назад і
відвів війська від українського кордону
Навіть якщо це російська територія Утім
попри те що висловлювання лідерів лівої
партії часу стають предметом суспільних
дискусій у Німеччині їхня підтримка
незначна рік тому на останніх виборах у
бундестаг за цю партію проголосували
лише 8% виборців справді більшість
німців не хочуть конфлікту з Росією але
це не означає що вони виправдовують
агресивні дії Кремля і розуміння того що
політика пряника стосовно Росії не
ефективна судячи з усього зростає
потрібна жорсткіша політика економічний
санкції слід скасувати там Чемпіонат
світу з футболу
Чесно кажучи я не згодний з політикою
росіян я не дипломат але гадаю шляхом
діалогу цей конфлікт не вирішити бо
Російський уряд до нині не виконав жод
ної обіцянки він ніби готовий на
поступки а потім порушує всі
домовленості
у чому одностайні мабуть усі німці - це
те що військо втручання у
російсько-українських конфлікт виключене
зараз Пріоритет у тому щоби зброя
замовкла на тривалий час і щоб ми
досягли політичного рішення рішення в
унісон із засадничими принципами
міжнародного права і за умов збереження
цілісності України
у питанні санкції проти Кремля Берлін
вочевидь зайняв чітку позицію А це
свідчить про те що Німеччина готується
до тривалої кризи у відносинах з Росією